so
for some folks that haven't seen an
interview of yours i think you did some
stuff with the folks at library congress
and other interviews you've done
what happened in uh with the great
influence if you want to kind of walk us
through with the story and some of the
stats
so the audience can come up to date oh
you know
uh uh an animal virus all influenza
viruses are actually
bird viruses they're all starting birds
so
in a sense they're all bird flu but
obviously they circulated mammals
uh and a new bird virus
jumped species to humans
uh we hadn't seen it before or at least
most hadn't seen before
there are eight gene segments in
influenza seven of them came directly
from birds one made it may have passed
through
another mammal before it got to humans
on the eighth it spread worldwide very
rapidly
you don't need airplanes to have a
pandemic there were
pandemics that made it from africa to
asia
to europe even to the americas going
back into the
1600s
it infected about the 1918 virus
infected about a third of the world's
population
it was much much deadlier than covet 19.
and it killed between 15 on coordinator
nobel laureate
uh made this estimate in the 1940s and
it's been confirmed by
modern epidemiologists
probably between 50 and 100 million
people died obviously that's a big range
if you adjust for population the world
back then was
less than a quarter of the size of
today's world so that would be
equivalent to 225
to 450 million people dead today
uh so the worst worst case scenarios for
covet 19
nothing like that uh thank god
uh and you know so that virus was much
more virulent
it it also killed these people
in an incredibly compressed period of
time probably two-thirds of the dead
died
in the fall of 1918. uh the pandemic
stretched over a couple of years
and in a particular city it was even
faster than that it would probably be
six to ten weeks
most of the people who died were
uh adults between the ages of 18 and 45
or 50 probably about two-thirds of the
dead so that's very different from covet
19 and very different from ordinary
influenza
possibly as many as eight percent of the
world's
population this would be on the worst
case
uh of people in the age group that age
group died
in a matter of weeks so
it was pretty violent and
the western world was at war and
because of the war uh every government
that was fighting was focused entirely
on the war
and for that reason
uh governments tended to minimize
the pandemic in the united states
wilson the president at the time never
made
a single public statement of any kind
about this pandemic
and in an effort to
there was a concern that any
that wilson didn't want any bad news
about anything
period we didn't want any
news that might hurt morale this had
nothing to do with the pandemic
they created an infrastructure in
advance of the pandemic
again nothing to do with the pandemic
something called the committee for
public information
a propaganda arm the architect of that
committee said nothing in experience
tells us that truth is superior to
falsehood the only thing that matters
is its impact on what you say so the
government
created this entity
that was geared toward telling lies
to keep morale up for the war
the government also passed a law that
made it punishable by 20 years in prison
to quote utter right print or publish
any disloyal profane scarless or abusive
language about the government of the
united states
that law was upheld by the supreme court
by oliver wendell holmes and an opinion
from two phrases from that opinion uh
survive one is you don't shout crowd
fire in a crowded theater
and uh clear and present danger and and
then the government enforce that law
vigorously they sent a
congressman sentenced to prison for 10
years a congressman
you're kidding me uh so this is the 1999
so that's yeah so that's the context on
the one hand
and again not prior to the pandemic
only because of the war the government
created an institution designed to lie
to keep morale up
and at the same time punish people for
criticizing any action by the government
so there that's the context that
influenza arrived in as a result
you have there's no tony fauci in 1918.
you had national public health leaders
associated with the government saying
things like this is ordinary influenza
by another name it was
called spanish influenza although it
didn't start in spain
uh and they are you had nothing to fear
if proper precautions are taken
and yet people could die less than
24 hours after the first symptoms and
they could die with horrific symptoms
to probably the scariest would be
they could bleed not only from their
nose and mouth
but from their eyes and ears that's a
pretty frightening symptom
uh so people are
dying in some cases with these horrible
symptoms
and in some cases very rapidly and a lot
of people are dying
and the government is telling you this
is ordinary influenza by another name
you have nothing to worry about
i could you know go into greater detail
but we're going to be talking for a long
time
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you